Bonjour à tous ! Aujourd'hui je voulais vous faire
une petite vidéo pour vous parler des prix Nobel,
donc les prix Nobel 2016 qui ont été annoncés cette semaine
et bien j'avais envie de vous les commenter un petit peu.
Donc je ne vais évidemment parler
que des prix Nobel dits scientifiques,
je vais parler du prix Nobel de médecine,
du prix Nobel de chimie et du prix Nobel de physique.
Alors on va commencer par le prix Nobel de médecine.
Cette année, il a été décerné à un Japonais
qui s'appelle Yoshinori Ohsumi,
pour ses travaux sur ce que l'on appelle l'autophagie.
Alors qu'est ce que c'est l'autophagie?
Et bien si l'on prend la racine grecque du mot,
autophagie ça veut dire "se manger soi-même".
Et donc l'autophagie, en fait c'est un mécanisme
qui existe au sein des cellules,
qui permet d'éliminer et de recycler des choses.
Alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire ?
Déjà on est tous faits de cellules,
tous les organismes vivants sont faits de cellules
et, au sein d'une cellule, en fait
on trouve tout un tas de choses.
Vous avez peut-être déjà vu, dans des livres de bio
par exemple, un schéma d'une cellule.
Et donc dans une cellule, on trouve tout un tas,
par exemple, de protéines
qui permettent d'assurer un certain nombre
de fonctions et aussi de construire des structures,
et on trouve tout un tas de structures qu'on regroupe
sous le terme générique d'organites.
Il arrive qu'une cellule soit toujours parfaitement fonctionnelle
mais qu'elle ait un certain nombre de protéines ou d'organites
qui soient, par exemple, devenus obsolètes
ou bien qui soient dégradés, abîmés et donc
qu'elle ait besoin de se débarrasser de tout ça.
Donc l'autophagie c'est un mécanisme
qui permet de faire ça.
Ce mécanisme a été découvert il y a déjà assez longtemps
puisqu'il a été découvert par un Belge
qui s'appelle Christian de Duve
qui avait déjà eu le prix Nobel dans les années 70.
Donc le principe de l'autophagie, c'est le suivant.
Imaginons que vous ayez des protéines ou bien
un organite dont la cellule veuille se débarrasser.
La cellule va commencer par construire une paroi autour,
sous la forme d'une double membrane,
pour enfermer ce dont elle souhaite se débarrasser,
qu'on appelle un autophagosome.
Ensuite cet autophagosome va être mis en contact
avec un autre type de de vésicule qu'on appelle un lysosome
qui contient un certain nombre d'enzymes,
qui est dans un milieu assez acide,
qui sont capables de digérer ce qui a été enfermé
dans l'autophagosome,
c'est-à-dire de digérer, de décomposer notamment les protéines.
Vous voyez que l'autophagosome, pour prendre une analogie,
c'est en quelque sorte le sac poubelle de la cellule.
Donc ce sac poubelle est amené en contact avec le lysosome
qu'on pourrait comparer, par exemple,
à un centre d'incinération des déchets.
En fait ce n'est pas tout à fait un centre d'incinération
des déchets puisque la beauté de la chose,
c'est que ce mécanisme d'autophagie permet
en fait de recycler la matière première,
c'est-à-dire que les protéines sont dégradées
mais on récupère les briques de base,
elles peuvent être réutilisées par la cellule
pour refaire de nouvelles protéines.
J'avais lu ce chiffre, il faudrait que je retrouve la source
parce que je ne sais plus exactement d'où ça vient,
mais en gros, le recyclage dû à l'autophagie
dans un corps humain typique,
ça représentait à peu près 200g à 300g de protéines.
Vous imaginez que si ces protéines étaient en fait
simplement dégradées et éliminées,
ça voudrait dire que pour assurer nos besoins en
protéines, en fait on devrait manger chaque jour
200g ou 300g de protéines en plus que ce qu'on mange déjà.
Vous voyez que c'est quand même
un mécanisme qui est assez efficace.
Alors du coup, Ohsumi qu'est ce qu'il a fait dans cette histoire ?
Je vous ai dit, ce n'est pas lui qui a découvert
le mécanisme de l'autophagie
mais c'est grâce à lui qu'on l'a beaucoup mieux compris
et qu'on a notamment pu comprendre
comment certains gènes jouaient un rôle là-dedans.
En fait, Ohsumi a procédé d'une manière
qui est assez intéressante.
La première chose qu'il a faite, c'est qu'il a décidé d'utiliser,
non pas des cellules humaines ou des cellules animales
mais de la levure de boulanger.
Vous savez peut-être que, contrairement à la levure
chimique qui est juste un produit chimique inerte,
la levure de boulanger c'est des organismes,
c'est des unicellulaires.
C'est un organisme qu'on utilise assez souvent
quand on veut étudier des phénomènes
de biologie moléculaire et cellulaire, notamment quand
on veut étudier des phénomènes qui sont assez basiques
et qui existent un peu chez tous les organismes.
Du coup, on utilise la levure de boulanger
parce que c'est assez pratique.
Donc il a utilisé la levure de boulanger
et ce qu'il avait envie de faire, c'était de faire des images,
de regarder au microscope ce qu'il se passait.
Le problème, c'est que les mécanismes de l'autophagie,
on ne les voit pas très bien,
c'est petit, ça ne dure pas longtemps
et en fait il a eu deux idées.
La première, c'est d'affamer ces levures de boulanger,
c'est-à-dire de ne pas leur donner de nutriments
et du coup, quand on affame les cellules
comme ça, en fait ça stimule l'autophagie.
Les cellules ont quand même besoin de matière
première, elle ont besoin d'énergie, de protéines
et si on ne leur en donne pas,
ça va stimuler le mécanisme de recyclage
pour qu'elles essayent de gratter là où elles peuvent.
Donc il a stimulé l'autophagie
chez les levures de boulanger en les affamant.
L'autre truc malin qu'il a fait,
c'est qu'il a désactivé le mécanisme
des enzymes qui sont dans le lysosome,
dans cette structure qui contient les enzymes
qui vont faire la digestion des protéines,
ce qui fait que, d'un côté il stimule l'autophagie,
donc il stimule le recyclage des déchets si vous voulez
et de l'autre côté, il désactive l'usine
qui est chargée de faire ce recyclage.
Et donc, qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
Il se passe la même chose qu'il se passerait chez vous
si jamais les éboueurs ne passaient pas,
les sacs poubelles s'accumulent.
Donc, comme ça, il a pu faire des clichés
de levures de boulanger
où on voyait dans les cellules tout un tas
d'autophagosomes s'accumuler
puisqu'ils ne pouvaient pas être digérés
par les enzymes du lysosome.
C'est comme ça qu'il a pu mettre en évidence ces autophagosomes
qu'autrement on avait beaucoup de mal à voir
parce que leur existence était assez transitoire,
ça dure seulement quelques minutes,
le temps que ce soit, normalement, ensuite digéré.
Une fois qu'il a mis au point cette méthode,
ça lui a permis de très bien visualiser ce phénomène
et donc il a pu l'étudier et notamment
étudier les gènes qui étaient impliqués.
La manière dont il a fait ça,
c'est qu'il a engendré un certain nombre de mutations
dans les gènes de la levure de boulanger,
il a regardé ce que ça changeait ou pas
au phénomène d'autophagie
et comme ça il a pu identifier une quinzaine de gènes
qui manifestement avaient un rôle déterminant pour l'autophagie,
ensuite il les a étudiés un par un en essayant de voir
quel était le rôle exact de chacun des gènes.
Voilà la contribution de Ohsumi qui nous permet
de mieux comprendre le principe de l'autophagie,
sachant que le principe de l'autophagie est quand même
important notamment du point de vue médical
puisqu'il y a un certain nombre de maladies qui peuvent
être associés à des dysfonctionnements de ce mécanisme.
Donc, voilà pour le prix Nobel de médecine,
on va passer au prix Nobel de chimie.
On va commencer par un petit cocorico parce qu'il a été
décerné à trois personnes dont un Français,
Jean-Pierre Sauvage, qui travaille à l'université de Strasbourg.
L'objet du prix Nobel de chimie cette année
était ce qu'on appelle les machines moléculaires.
Qu'est-ce que c'est une machine moléculaire ?
En gros, c'est l'idée de fabriquer une ou des molécules
qui se comportent un peu comme
des machines qu'on a à notre échelle,
c'est-à-dire qui soient capables d'effectuer
un certain nombre de mouvements bien contrôlés
en réponse à un stimulus, par exemple à un apport d’énergie.
Sur le papier, on aurait envie de penser
que ce n'est pas trop compliqué,
il suffit de faire des molécules qui miment un peu des machines.
En fait, si on regarde un petit peu plus profond, c'est
compliqué, je vais essayer de vous expliquer pourquoi.
Si on prend une molécule, j'ai pris un modèle de molécule,
je crois que c'est la caféine, je ne sais plus très bien,
en fait, une molécule on voit que c'est fait de liaisons
et du coup, l'ensemble est quand même assez rigide,
je peux prendre ma molécule, je peux la tordre un peu,
mais vous voyez que je ne peux pas effectuer
des rotations avec par exemple,
je ne peux pas effectuer des mouvements
tels qu'on aurait par exemple avec des roues.
Si on s'amuse à faire la comparaison,
par exemple là j'ai pris un petit bout de Lego Technic,
vous voyez, ici j'ai un axe et mon axe peut tourner
et c'est quoi la grosse différence entre ça
et une molécule normale, on va dire,
c'est que la molécule est rigide, tout est lié avec tout
et donc on ne peut pas avoir des mouvements
du type de celui qu'on a avec un axe
qui passerait dans un trou.
Vous voyez bien qu'ici l'axe et le bout de Lego ne sont pas liés,
ils sont contraints quand on les met ensemble
mais ils ne sont pas liés.
Si on veut espérer faire quelque chose qui ressemble
à des machines à l'échelle moléculaire,
il faut qu'on arrive à mimer ce genre de principe.
Ce qu'il faut qu'on fasse, c'est faire des molécules
dont certaines parties ne soient pas liées
par des liaisons chimiques,
mais soient simplement enchevêtrées
comme on a pu l'avoir ici avec l'axe et la brique de Lego.
Je vous montre un exemple, ça c'est des molécules
qui n'existent pas mais c'est juste pour vous montrer.
En fait, j'ai deux molécules qui sont
de forme un peu circulaire, comme ça
et on pourrait imaginer que ces molécules soient enchevêtrées.
Quand on a deux molécules qui sont enchevêtrées, vous
voyez qu'elles peuvent avoir des mouvements libres,
pourtant, elles restent quand même ensemble.
Des molécules de ce genre là, en fait
on sait en faire, ça s'appelle des caténanes
et la question est, comment on fait pour arriver à faire
des molécules qui soient enchevêtrées comme ça.
En fait c'est très compliqué et pendant longtemps,
la seule méthode qu'on avait,
c'est qu'on faisait des molécules en cercle, comme ça
et puis on pariait sur le fait que de temps en temps, par coup de bol,
quand on les faisait et que les cercles se refermaient,
par coup de bol, on pouvait espérer
en avoir deux qui soient enchevêtrées.
On savait faire ces caténanes mais c'était très très inefficace .
Donc, toute la beauté du travail de l'équipe
de Sauvage à Strasbourg ça a été de trouver
une manière de faire ces molécules-là de manière
beaucoup plus efficace, avec un rendement de 90%,
c'est pour ça que c'est vraiment un vrai prix Nobel de chimie.
Je dis ça parce que, de temps en temps, le prix Nobel
de chimie on le donne plutôt pour des travaux
de biologie moléculaire qu'on ne peut pas vraiment
récompenser avec le prix Nobel de médecine,
alors on leur donne le prix Nobel de chimie.
Là, c'est un vrai prix Nobel de chimie,
l'art du chimiste est de trouver une voie de synthèse
pour fabriquer des molécules
et donc l'équipe de Sauvage a trouvé une voie de synthèse,
c'est-à-dire un certain nombre de réactifs,
une procédure, des catalyseurs, etc...,
pour arriver à fabriquer des molécules enchevêtrées.
Ça a commencé avec des caténanes
qu'on savait déjà faire mais que, grâce à lui,
on a pu faire de manière beaucoup plus efficace
et ensuite un certain nombre d'autres types
de molécules, ça a vraiment ouvert des portes
sur quelle est la manière de faire
la synthèse de molécules comme ça.
On peut citer d'autres exemples, il y a
ce qu'on appelle par exemple les rotaxanes
où cette fois ce n'est pas tout à fait ça, il faut
imaginer une longue chaîne plutôt droite
et une molécule plutôt circulaire
qu'on arriverait à mettre dessus
puis on met des choses ici pour bloquer et donc on a
quelque chose qui peut tourner comme autour d'un axe.
Voilà, ça a été la grande contribution de Sauvage
de trouver toutes ces voies de synthèse
qui ont pu permettre de faire des molécules
qui avaient des enchevêtrements et des formes
qui étaient très différentes de ce qu'on savait faire avant
et donc il a notamment fait des choses
avec des topologies un peu bizarres,
ça parlera aux mathématiciens qui aiment bien
la théorie des nœuds ou la théorie des tresses,
par exemple des molécules qui avaient la forme de
nœuds, c'est-à-dire qui se renouaient sur elles-mêmes.
Donc ça, ça a ouvert la voie à plein de travaux
sur les machines moléculaires
et une des personnes qui a été récompensée avec lui,
qui s'appelle Ben Feringa,
a été le premier à arriver à exploiter tous ces principes
pour faire des mouvements qui
commençaient à être vraiment complexes
et il a fait notamment ce qu'on a appelé
un peu malicieusement la première "nano-voiture",
c'est-à-dire une structure avec quelque chose
qui peut vraiment s'apparenter à des roues
et qui est capable de bouger.
Alors, quelque chose qui est quand même important,
c'est que comme une vraie machine,
ces molécules qui sont capables d'avoir des mouvements
ne vont pas faire des mouvements comme ça,
spontanément, "gratuitement",
comme une vraie machine il faut les alimenter avec de l'énergie
et notamment, les structures créées par Feringa
sont capables de réagir par exemple à un stimulus qui
peut être une impulsion lumineuse ou ce genre de chose.
Il y a un truc qu'il faut dire,
c'est qu'en matière de machines moléculaires
on est absolument ridicules
par rapport à ce que sait faire la vie.
On connait tout un tas de merveilleuses
machines moléculaires qui sont dans nos corps,
l'exemple le plus simple c'est ce qui se passe avec nos muscles,
nos muscles sont des machines, ils sont capables de réagir et d'effectuer un mouvement
en réponse à un stimuli en dépensant de l'énergie et tout ça
et parce qu'il existe des molécules très très complexes
qui sont synthétisées par notre corps,
des protéines, tout ça, qui sont capables
de faire ces mouvements très compliqués.
Des machines moléculaires, on en connait déjà plein,
elles sont très compliquées, c'est la vie qui les a créées,
vous pouvez penser à d'autres choses comme
par exemple le flagelle du spermatozoïde,
c'est une jolie machine moléculaire.
Donc, on est vraiment à l'enfance de ce domaine-là
par rapport à ce qu'on sait qu'on pourrait faire si on
maîtrisait un peu tous les principes qui étaient derrière
et donc il va certainement se passer
des choses dans ce domaine là.
On peut déjà imaginer un certain nombre d'applications
notamment à partir du moment où on serait capables de
faire des molécules qui seraient un peu plus intelligentes,
qui seraient capables d'effectuer certaines fonctions,
de trier certaines cibles, etc...
Voilà, il y a des perspectives énormes mais,
encore une fois, on n'en est qu'au début
et tout ça c'est grâce à l'art des chimistes qui sont
capables de trouver des voies de synthèse très originales
pour arriver à vraiment produire ces molécules,
la clé ce n'est pas juste de les imaginer sur le papier
et de les dessiner, c'est comment on fait pour les fabriquer.
Je vais passer au dernier prix
qui est le prix Nobel de physique,
ça va être peut-être le plus complexe des trois.
C'est un prix qui a été décerné cette année
à des gens qui font de la physique théorique.
Vous savez que moi, dans le passé,
j'ai fait de la physique théorique
et quand je parle de physique théorique sur la chaîne,
généralement je vous parle de physique des particules,
de cosmologie, de théorie quantique des champs,
des choses qui sont liées plutôt à ce qu'est
la matière au niveau fondamental
et en fait ça pourrait laisser croire que la physique
théorique ce n'est que ça, mais en fait ce n'est pas que ça.
Il y a notamment tout un tas de travaux qui sont
vraiment très intéressants et très riches
dans un domaine qu'on appelle
la physique de la matière condensée.
Qu'est-ce que c'est la matière condensée ?
Pour faire simple, c'est les liquides et les solides.
Il y a beaucoup de travaux en physique de la matière condensée,
de travaux théoriques et aussi expérimentaux
et ce qui est amusant c'est que c'est un peu le contraire
de ce qu'on fait dans la physique théorique
des particules par exemple.
En physique des particules, on prend des choses complexes
et on essaye de les casser
en des morceaux les plus petits possibles
pour essayer de voir quels sont
les constituants élémentaires,
c'est vraiment de descendre à l’échelle
la plus petite pour voir de quoi tout ça est fait.
En physique de la matière condensée c'est un peu
l’approche inverse, on prend des particules,
par exemple des atomes, dont on pense qu'on sait à peu
près comment ils se comportent, on les met ensemble,
on peut faire un liquide, on peut faire
un cristal, un solide cristallin
et on essaye de voir quelles sont
les propriétés qui apparaissent.
C'est une discipline qui est vraiment très intéressante
qui a commencé il y a longtemps,
on a commencé à s’intéresser d'un point de vue
théorique aux propriétés des liquides et des solides
principalement au début du 20ème siècle et notamment
grâce à l'emergence de la mécanique quantique.
Les premières choses qu'on a étudiées,
qu'on a comprises relativement vite, par exemple,
c'est tout simplement pourquoi certains corps,
certains solides sont conducteurs
de l'électricité et pas d'autres,
pourquoi il y a des métaux et des isolants.
Ça c'est des choses qu'on a pu comprendre
avec une théorie qu'on appelle la théorie des bandes
qui est un dérivé de la mécanique quantique
et qui nous a permis aussi de comprendre quelque
chose de très important, c'est les semi-conducteurs,
pour faire simple, c'est à mi-chemin
entre un métal et un isolant.
Les semi-conducteurs sont super importants
parce que c'est grâce à eux
qu'on fait des transistors, de l'électronique,
des microprocesseurs, etc...
Donc si jamais vous êtes capables de regarder
cette vidéo sur votre ordinateur,
sur votre téléphone, tout ça, c'est grâce aux semi-conducteurs.
Si on fait des panneaux photovoltaïques,
c'est grâce aux semi-conducteurs,
voilà, c'est essentiel dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
donc le prochain qui me dit que
la physique théorique ne sert à rien ...
Ça c'est des choses qu'on maîtrise assez bien
depuis la première moitié du 20ème siècle
et en fait c'est des choses qui ont été assez faciles,
toute proportions gardées, sur le plan théorique
parce que quand on considère, par exemple
un métal, qui conduit l'électricité,
on se rend compte que pour comprendre
comment il fonctionne,
on peut simplement considérer les électrons
comme étant des objets un peu indépendants,
c'est-à-dire qu'on part du principe que les électrons n'interagissent pas trop,
ils ne se voient pas trop, en quelque sorte, les uns les autres
et finalement ça fonctionne assez bien, ça permet
de comprendre comment fonctionnent les métaux,
de comprendre comment fonctionnent les isolants
et les semi-conducteurs, dans une certaine mesure.
En fait, il existe tout un tas de domaines
où on ne peut plus ignorer ça, on ne peut plus faire comme
si les électrons ne se voyaient pas les uns les autres,
c'est ce qu'on appelle parfois le domaine
des fermions fortement corrélés
et c'est un sujet extrêmement difficile parce que
si vous prenez un morceau de solide,
il y a un paquet d'électrons dedans et donc si tous
les électrons interagissent avec tous les électrons,
ça fait une quantité d'interactions qui est vraiment
très compliquée à appréhender.
Pourquoi je vous parle de tout ça ?
Je vais en venir au sujet du prix Nobel.
Une des choses qu'on étudie beaucoup quand on fait
de la physique de la matière condensée,
c'est notamment les phases de la matière
On dit classiquement qu'il y a trois phases de la matière,
liquide, solide et gazeux,
parfois on rajoute le plasma, là on dit qu'il y en a quatre.
En fait ce n'est pas vrai, il y en a beaucoup plus que ça,
il n'y en a pas que ni trois ni quatre,
Il y a tout un tas de phases de la matière qu'on connait
mais qui sont des phases qu'on appelle plutôt exotiques.
La raison pour laquelle elles sont exotiques,
c'est qu'on ne les croise pas tous les jours
et notamment on ne les croise que quand
on descend à des températures très basses.
Il y a deux exemples qui sont très importants,
c'est la supraconductivité et la superfluidité.
Qu'est-ce que c'est la supraconductivité ?
C'est le fait que certains solides, quand
on les refroidit à des températures très basses,
se mettent à conduire l'électricité sans aucune résistance.
Ça, on a envie de penser que c'est quelque chose
d'assez original, d'assez anormal,
parce que même les métaux qui conduisent très bien
l'électricité ont en fait toujours une petite résistance,
alors que les supraconducteurs, non,
ils ont une résistance nulle,
c'est-à-dire qu'ils propagent le courant
sans aucune résistance.
Donc ça c'est assez formidable et ça a un certain
nombre d'applications par exemple dans des IRM,
un certain nombre de transports à lévitation, etc...
Donc, c'est la supraconductivité.
L'autre sujet qui est assez intéressant dont on entend
souvent parler, c'est ce qu'on appelle la superfluidité,
c'est un peu un phénomène cousin,
donc là c'est plutôt dans des liquides
qui vont, en dessous d'une certaine température,
par exemple ça se produit avec l'hélium,
se mettre à couler sans aucune viscosité,
sans aucun frottement
donc le liquide devient superfluide.
Ça c'est des phénomènes qui sont très intrigants
et qu'on a voulu comprendre sur le plan théorique
et par exemple pour la supraconductivité, en fait
on a une théorie de la supraconductivité,
mais elle n'explique que les phénomènes de
supraconductivité en dessous d'une certaine température,
bon, ce n'est pas tout à fait ça mais ça n'explique
qu'une partie de la supraconductivité,
seulement la supraconductivité de certains corps.
Il existe tout un tas de solides qui sont
supraconducteurs à des températures plus élevées
que ce que prédirait la théorie dont je vous ai parlé
et ceux-là, on ne sait pas du tout expliquer
pourquoi ils sont supraconducteurs,
pourquoi cette supraconductivité
qu'on appelle haute température existe.
Alors on dit haute température, mais
ça reste quand même très très froid.
Ça c'est une question qui est vraiment
extrêmement intéressante
parce que, imaginez qu'on comprenne mieux ça et
qu'on soit capables de fabriquer des supraconducteurs
peut-être qui fonctionneraient à température ambiante,
ça permettrait de transporter du courant
à température ambiante sans pertes donc
ça serait vraiment quelque chose d'incroyable.
La supraconductivité haute température,
aujourd'hui, personne ne la comprend,
personne n'a de théorie qui vraiment explique
la supraconductivité haute température.
Je peux vous dire que le premier qui va se pointer
avec une théorie convaincante de ça
peut directement prendre son billet pour Stockholm
et aller chercher son prix Nobel.
On n'en est pas encore là, mais il y a tout un tas d'autres
phénomènes qui sont un peu connexes à ça
qui concernent des changements de phase
un peu exotiques comme ça
qu'on essaye d'étudier dans l'espoir que ça nous amène
à une meilleure compréhension de ce qu'il se passe,
notamment dans les supraconducteurs.
Pourquoi je vous parle de tout ça ?
C'est que les trois qui ont eu le prix Nobel de physique cette année,
qui s'appellent Kosterlitz, Thouless et Haldane,
ont travaillé sur certaines phases, certains
changements de phase un peu exotiques de la matière.
C'est vraiment exotique parce que, d'une part ça se
produit aussi à des températures qui sont très basses
et en plus, eux, ils ont étudié spécifiquement des
systèmes qui sont ce qu'on appelle en basse dimension,
ça veut dire en deux dimensions ou en une dimension.
Alors, ça peut paraître un peu stupide parce qu'on sait
très bien qu'on vit dans un monde en trois dimensions,
la matière est en trois dimension,
mais en fait il existe un certain nombre de systèmes
qui sont des systèmes en deux dimensions.
Par exemple, si on fait des films
très minces de supraconducteurs,
ils vont se comporter comme des films en deux dimensions.
Ça marche aussi, par exemple, avec des films de superfluides
et aussi maintenant on est même capables de faire
des structures qui soient vraiment bidimensionnelles,
on a pas mal parlé ces dernières années du graphène,
qui a eu le prix Nobel il y a quelques années, d’ailleurs.
Le graphène c'est vraiment une structure bidimensionnelle,
c'est une feuille de carbone qui a un atome d’épaisseur.
Donc, ces gens-là ont étudié des changements
de phase un peu exotiques
qui se passaient dans des corps
en deux dimensions et en une dimension.
Je ne vais pas rentrer dans les détails
parce que c'est vraiment compliqué,
si j'ai le courage j'essaierai de faire
un billet de blog sur le sujet,
je mettrai le lien quelque part donc si le lien ne marche
pas c'est que je n'ai pas eu le courage de faire le billet.
Ce qu'ils ont fait c'est que, d'un point de vue théorique,
ils ont trouvé des changements de phase,
notamment un type de changement
de phase qu'on appelle la transition KT,
pour Kosterlitz Thouless,
qui en fait a des propriétés
qu'on n'avait jamais imaginées avant,
on ne pensait pas que ce type de changement de phase
pouvait exister, ils l'ont trouvé sur le plan théorique
et ensuite on a fait un certain nombre d'expériences
qui ont permis de vérifier qu'en fait ils avaient raison,
ça marchait vraiment comme ça
dans certains systèmes bidimensionnels.
En plus il y a quelque chose d'assez magique
avec ces théories sur les changements de phase,
c'est qu'il y a un peu une notion d'universalité,
c'est-à-dire qu'une fois qu'on a compris un modèle,
il peut être suffisamment générique et s'appliquer
à tout un tas de systèmes différents
et donc il y a tout un tas de systèmes
qui ont l'air assez peu reliés les uns aux autres
comme des films de supraconducteurs, des films d'hélium
ou des espèces de réseaux planaires
de jonctions supraconductrices
qui, en fait, suivent tous la théorie de la transition KT.
Ils ont vraiment découvert de nouveaux types de
changements de phase assez exotiques dans la matière,
on appelle ça parfois les phases topologiques
pour des raisons que je vous passe,
la manière dont on décrit les phases
et les changements de phase
fait appel à un certain nombre
de notions plutôt de topologie
pour ceux qui connaissent la topologie en mathématiques.
Voilà, ça c'était pour le prix Nobel de physique.
J'espère que ce petit descriptif vous aura permis
d'y voir un petit peu plus clair
sur quels étaient les prix Nobel de cette année
et au-delà des gens à qui on les donne,
parce qu'on les donne toujours à quelques personnes
alors qu'il y a toujours des tas d'équipes derrière,
essayer de vous faire comprendre pourquoi
on considère que ces sujets sont importants,
quand on file le Nobel c'est parce que
c'est quelque chose d'important
et je voudrais essayer de vous faire sentir
pourquoi ces choses étaient importantes.
Voilà, comme je vous le disais, je ferai peut-être un petit billet
pour expliquer un petit peu plus le prix Nobel de physique,
d'ici là, si vous voulez une vidéo
sur un mode un petit peu plus normal,
enfin pas tout à fait normal, un petit peu différent,
j'ai collaboré il n'y a pas longtemps
avec la chaîne String Theory.
J'ai fait un petit épisode avec eux,
il y en aura d'autres mais j'ai fait un épisode avec eux
sur l'acoustique et la physique du son, je vous
le recommande, vous pouvez aller jeter un œil.
Voilà, d'ici là je vous dis à très bientôt
et continuez d'aimer la science.
Merci, à bientôt.